[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe et bouffe sommet des chefs d'état
de l'union européenne
un peu plus tôt mini-sommet à 4 à
versailles berlin madrid paris et rome
ont plaidé pour une europe à plusieurs
vitesses pour en parler
j'accueille deux eurodéputés jean
arthuis bonjour vous êtes député
européen français 1 du groupe de
l'alliance des démocrates et libéraux
pour l'europe en france vous avez été
élu sous les couleurs de lui dit vous
êtes ancien ministre de l'économie vous
soutenez emmanuel macron candidat à
l'élection présidentielle face à vous
marc tarabella
bonjour merci d'être venu vous êtes
député européen belge du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et je soutiens
benoît hamon et vous souhaitez benoît
hamon depuis la belgique
mais d'abord les images ce mini sommet
européen à versailles france allemagne
italie espagne pour tenter de relancer
l'europe après le break site françois
hollande et en gala merkel veulent jouer
la carte d'une europe à plusieurs
vitesses on regarde et on réagit juste
après
le lieu est symbolique à versailles
françois hollande reçoit les trois
autres dirigeants les plus importants
d'europe l'allemagne l'italie et
l'espagne
ils représentent les plus fortes
populations et les produits intérieurs
bruts les plus importantes ils sont
venus parler d'une entité malades
l'europe c'est un fait
l'élargissement de l'europe s'est changé
en un processus nébuleux qui rend
l'union européenne
incompréhensible au peuple la montée des
extrêmes à la teste à versailles
nos quatre dirigeants ont tenté de
lancer les bases d'un noyau dur
européens pour aller plus vite
l'unité n'est pas l'uniformité et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je plaide pour
qu'il y ait de nouvelles formes de
coopération pour de nouveaux projets ce
qu'on appelle les coopérations
différenciée qui fasse que quelques pays
puisse aller plus vite plus aller plus
loin dans des domaines comme la défense
comme la zone euro à travers
l'approfondissement de l'union
économique et monétaire comme
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale comme
la culture en gueule à merkel en
campagne pour une réélection en
septembre en est convaincu une europe à
plusieurs vitesses c'est la solution
je voudrais souligner ce que françois
hollande a dit tout à l'heure
nous devons avoir le courage d'accepter
que certains pays aille de l'avant
et puis avancez un peu plus rapidement
que d'autres
il faut bien sûr que ces coopérations
différencier reste ouverte à ceux qui
sont un peu plus en retard il ne faut
pas que ce soit fermée pour ceux qui ont
pris du retard mais il faut pouvoir
aller de l'avant
les dirigeants des quatre pays les plus
peuplés de l'union européenne
retrouveront leur homologue le 25 mars
dans la capitale italienne à l'occasion
du 60e anniversaire du traité de rome
mission relancer le projet européen
[Musique]
voilà question à vous 2 1 messieurs est
ce que cette europe à plusieurs vitesses
c'est la solution pour relancer le
projet européen jean arthuis oui d'abord
l'europe à plusieurs vitesses elle
existe la zone euro rassemble 19 états
membres alors que le marché intérieur
est à 28,27 demain je pense que les
propos que tiennent les chefs d'état qui
se sont rencontrés à versailles vont
dans la bonne direction parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien que du fait
de la mondialisation les états à eux
seuls ne peuvent pas assumer ne peuvent
plus assumer un certain nombre de
prérogatives de souveraineté on a évoqué
la défense devrait parler des migrations
aubrée parler de la lutte contre le
terrorisme de la politique économique et
de la nécessité de lutter contre le
chômage
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes en face
d'une double impuissance impuissance au
plan national et impuissance au plan
européen cette situation ne peut pas
durer si on a mis en oeuvre un projet
européen c'est pour faire de l'europe
une puissance mondiale et redonner
l'espoir et la confiance à nos
concitoyens
faute de quoi ils sont exaspérés et
peuvent être réceptif aux propos que
tiennent à certains nombres de populisme
et de refaire ma carabine à un françois
hollande va plus loin il dit le risque
pour l'europe ces deux sombres et a
carrément la solution serait une europe
à plusieurs vitesses avec une direction
politique confiée aux grands pays
vous dites quoi jeudi mme holland a
raison de faire le constat et d'essai
d'amorcer des solutions pour sortir de
l'impasse dans laquelle nous sommes au
niveau européen car quand on critique
parfois l'immobilisme de l'union
européenne ou le manque de réactivité ou
de pro activité
c'est davantage la faute des
gouvernements qui en sort n'arrive plus
à faire un projet n'arrive plus à
s'entendre ne résolvent pas concrètement
certaines crises regardez les migrants
la proposition de solution était venue
de la commission européenne le parlement
soutenait cette solidarité entre pays et
c'est finalement quelques gouvernements
qui ne veulent pas jouer cette
solidarité et le projet évidemment on ne
peut pas aboutir
c'est vrai dans toute une série d'autres
domaines donc je dirais que cette
coopération renforcée entre plusieurs
états est un mal nécessaire mais je dis
attention à ces chefs d'état des quatre
grands pays qui ont une légitimité et le
grip et benelux donc ensemble
la version européenne
il rejoint plus de la moitié population
européenne cela étant dit n'oubliez pas
d'autres pays fondateurs la belgique
notamment le grand duché luxembourg des
pays qui ont toujours été fédéraliste
les pays-bas maintenant sont un peu plus
dubitatif mais les pays-bas n'oubliez
pas non plus mais ne nous limitons pas
au pays fondateurs il ya aussi des pays
comme les pays baltes ou la suède le
danemark qui sont dans l'union
européenne qui apportent leur
contribution
et n'oublions pas la zone euro est
probablement un socle intéressant
donc ne nous limitons pas aux grands
pays c'est une bonne base de départ mais
elle doit fédérer d'autres états et
faire redémarrer comme jean marty
ladhuie le projet européen
c'est hélas je le répète un mal
nécessaire qui failli créer cette europe
à plusieurs vitesses qu'aujourd'hui
l'europe ne fonctionne l'europe 28
bientôt à 27 c est un paquebot
impossible à à manoeuvrer rapidement on
voit bien que l'europe aujourd'hui
dysfonctionne et ne laissons pas la
critique aux europhobes et aux
nationalistes
il nous appartient de critiquer ce
fonctionnement parce que nous voulons
une europe dotée d'un véritable
gouvernement
une europe qui puisse prendre des
décisions une europe qui puisse résoudre
les problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aux problèmes de sécurité
les problèmes de maîtrise des flux
migratoires aux frontières extérieures
or aujourd'hui nous sommes dans le court
termisme court termisme absolue on ne
prend pas de décision on est bloqué par
l'unanimité
ceci ne peut pas durer une vie donc
n'empêcheront pas ceux qui veulent aller
de l'avant d'être les moteurs de ce
mouvement européen
nous sommes dans la globalisation et
l'inspirent la peur quelquefois
l'angoissent à nos concitoyens parce que
le monde est devenu dangereux voit bien
qu'en matière de climat on pourrait bien
un jour rendre la vie impossible sur la
planète
on voit bien que si je produisais demain
une crise financière comme celle de 2007
ce pourrait être un véritable tsunami
économique et social les déséquilibres
sont partout il va falloir organiser le
monde qui peut avoir une influence dans
l'organisation de ce monde
sinon l'europe est ce que les membres
fondateurs pousse davantage à
l'intégration pour faire pression sur
les ex pays de l'est sur l'impression
que c'est une réaction aussi à
l'attitude des pays de l'est
il ne faut pas mettre tous les pays de
l'ex bloc de l'est dans le même dans le
même sac je pense qu'à le groupe de
viser grade
il faudra deux manières mans les villes
allemagne elles avaient été choqués par
le refus de la pologne la hongrie 2 de
l'aider dans la migra thouars pologne
hongrie république tchèque et slovaquie
sont quatre pays à part qui refusent
très souvent parure au scepticisme
parfois parures aux phobies c'est
étonnant mais c'est comme ça il se
l'europe devient pour eux finalement une
en belgique on appelle ça une cash
machine ou en tout cas un bon contact
voilà c'est à dire un distributeur
d'argent mais si l'europe n'est plus que
ça pour eux alors effectivement il faut
soit question de l'intérêt de garder ces
pays à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
et il doit se poser eux-mêmes la
question clairement mais tous les pays
je pense à la slovénie par exemple je
pense à 12 oui d'autres pays qui ont
intégré et chypre malte ça c'était pas
le bloc de l'est
mais j'ai percé des pays baltes
notamment il faut pas remettre en cause
de participation ces pays bas sont
clairement encore pro européens
participent à la décision européenne et
n'ont pas manifesté de réaction en tout
cas de manque de solidarité par rapport
à certains dossiers et donc ne craignons
pas non plus une césure là où il y en a
pas mais par contre effectivement par
rapport à certains pays
malheureusement les traités ne
permettent pas aujourd'hui de mettre en
examen si le terme très très forts de
l'actualité française
mais certains pays qui dérape par
rapport aux valeurs européen je pense à
la hongrie à sauve acquis notamment la
pologne
puisqu'il faut l'unanimité des autres
quand on veut mettre un pays sous la
lumière et examinés parfois le la
constitutionnalité en tout cas de
certaines lois qu'ils prennent les fonds
c'est qu'on est sensible à ce qu'on va
pas reléguer les pays de l'est dans un
cercle de deuxième jaune il aurait la
première zone et puis après la deuxième
zone
non mais il faut quand même
connaissaient pas les risques sont que
les choses soient claires
naturellement la solidarité joue à jouer
entre les états membres de l'union
européenne
c'est l'objet des fonds de cohésion les
états qui sont qui ont des niveaux de
produit intérieur brut les plus élevées
par habitant doivent apporter une aide
aux pays qui doivent progresser et se
mettre à niveau
mais pas dans n'importe quelles
conditions on accepte l'argent mais on
récuse les droits fondamentaux les
principes de respect des droits de
l'homme de démocratie
ceci ne peut pas continuer il pourrait y
avoir à mon avis à l'avenir une
conditionnalité
c'est à dire que en contrepartie des
aides que l'on reçoit on s'engage à
respecter les principes fondateurs de
l'union européenne on a été trop loin
dans l'élargissement alors c'est ça un
peu vite on l'a mal préparés on a élargi
avant d'approfondir le mécanisme de
décision d'une part aujourd'hui que
certaines règles sont encore devant
recueillir l'unanimité pour être
d'application est une absurdité à 28 ou
même à 27
donc ça a été mal préparée et puis
clairement le fait de probablement de ne
pas voir adapter certaines règles je
pense à une directive qui aujourd'hui
est utilisée abusivement par les grandes
entreprises notamment du secteur de la
construction mais aussi du transport
mais aussi de l'aide aux personnes mais
aussi du nettoyage c'est la directrice
se détachant des travailleurs qui
aujourd'hui fait des ravages
quatre cent mille polonais viennent
travailler dans le reste de l'europe qui
sont remplacés par quatre cent mille
ukrainien qui viennent travailler pour
moins cher en pologne
ça c'est le dumping social et cette
directive doit être refondée aller sur
la table du parlement aujourd'hui de la
commune la commission fait une
proposition et certains pays ne veulent
pas changer mais il faut changer les
règles parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
claire concurrence entre pays entre
systèmes sociaux entre travailleurs et
ça ça ne peut plus durer il faut
réaffirmer un principe qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas d'actualité
c'est que les lois sociales et les
impôts inhérents à un travail dans cette
rue paix dans le pays où a lieu cette
prestation service de ce pays est arrêté
avec ce principe du pays d'origine qui
minent aujourd'hui les cieux européens
c'est très choquant quand on voit une
personne venant des pays de l'est de
travailler sur des chantiers de travaux
publics en belgique ou en france c'est
très choquant de constater les écarts
de législation qui encadre le travail
mais lorsqu'on construit des voitures
dans certains pays de l'europe de l'est
et qu'elle vienne sur le marché belge où
le marché français c'est exactement le
même
le même phénomène donc l'urgence c'est
la mise en convergence des législations
fiscales des législations sociales du
droit du travail
les législations environnementales faute
de quoi l'europe pourrait bien un jour
imploser allez on passe à la partie
magazine on s'intéresse à la lutte
contre l'échec scolaire 40% des élèves
de milieux défavorisés sont en
difficulté en france c'est ce que nous
apprenait le rapport pisa
on est allé voir comment cela se passe
en finlande ce petit pays arrive
régulièrement en tête du classement
scolaire pisa de l'oscd eu sa recette du
pragmatisme et des moyens leur reportage
de céline martel
des adolescents qui jouent avec leur
téléphone portable en plein cours de
mathématiques
ici pas de remontrances c'est leur
enseignante qui a préparé ce quiz
accessible en ligne via une application
mobile
les élèves s'amusent ils ne se rendent
pas compte qu'ils sont en train de
travailler d'apprendre les faire
utiliser les ordinateurs ou les
portables c'est aussi un moyen de les
rendre actif dans leur apprentissage en
finlande
les enseignants jouissent d'une grande
autonomie dans leur travail ils sont
libres d'adapter leurs méthodes à leurs
élèves
ce qui frappe aussi c'est le nombre
d'adultes dans une classe qui ne compte
que 18 enfants
en plus de la professeure il y a en
permanence une éducatrice spécialisée en
finlande
nous proposons du soutien individuel à
chaque élève
je travaille en collaboration avec le
professeur de mathématiques
mon travail c'est de repérer et d'aider
les enfants qui ont le plus de
difficulté à ne pas décrocher à suivre
la classe élite phase avec ce suivi
personnalisé le redoublement est une
chose rarissime en finlande
autre pilier de l'éducation finlandaise
la grande liberté laissée aux élèves et
cela dès leur plus jeune âge panu
enseigne à une classe de sixième et
comme tous les lundis il leur présente
le programme de la semaine
à eux ensuite organiser leur travail ça
c'était le programme des choses à
apprendre la semaine dernière en
mathématiques et en sciences
chaque élève a choisi donc quel ordre il
a fait ses exercices et ensuite c'est
auto évaluer grâce à cette grille de
couleur vert ça veut dire par exemple
j'ai compris et je veux en savoir d'ici
pas deux journées entières sur une
chaise
les enfants se déplacent librement dans
la classe pour comparer leurs résultats
et s'entraîner et quand ils seront plus
grands ils composeront eux mêmes leur
emploi du temps au lycée c'est l'élève
qui choisit ses matières et parmi ces
matières il y a les travaux pratiques en
finlande un cours de menuiserie c'est
aussi important qu'un cours de maths et
c'est obligatoire pour les pilotes
travailler avec ses mains ça aide les
enfants à réfléchir différemment
ça leur donne le goût de réaliser des
choses par eux-mêmes de poursuivre leur
apprentissage
même s'ils ne sont pas très bons dans
les matières académiques
les élèves termineront leur coffret en
bois une prochaine fois
il est 2 heures 15 l'école c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui
l'emploi du temps respecte les rythme
biologique des enfants et leur laisse
beaucoup de temps pour les activités
extrascolaires
[Musique]
marie-aude et une française qui a
emménagé près d'helsinki il y a trois
ans avec toute sa famille très vite elle
a senti les bénéfices de cet emploi du
temps allégé sur son fils
qu est-ce qu avec lesquels je me
souviens d'en france récupérer mon
garçon temps du stress et fatigue et
afin que 88 5 heures le soir là ils ont
passé tout l'après-midi dehors ils sont
beaucoup plus détendu
franchement depuis quand mr hiver en
finlande petit à petit s'est ouvert il a
vraiment pris confiance en lui rien que
pour ça je je remercie l'école
finlandaise ça c'est certain
la finlande 2 représente aujourd'hui un
exemple en terme de politique
d'éducation nationale pacis halberg a
longtemps conseiller le ministère de
l'enseignement finlandais il est
aujourd'hui invité partout dans le monde
pour conseiller les gouvernements en
matière d'éducation
pour lui le secret de la réussite c'est
le temps je pense que la finlande est
très différente des autres pays parce
que nous donnons du temps pour que les
réformes de l'éducation et portent leurs
fruits dans beaucoup de pays
il essaie une réforme pendant deux trois
ans puis ils changent en finlande
ça fait 30 ans que nous travaillons sur
notre système actuel
une continuité qui place la finlande en
tête des pays européens en matière de
résultats scolaires
depuis une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
alors reportage de céline martel en
finlande de suivi personnalisé liberté
laissée aux élèves le modèle finlandais
est il transposable en france en
belgique
j'en suis je pense qu'on peut s'en
inspirer j'ai tout l'intérêt de l'europe
d'ailleurs c'est de comparer les
pratiques et de s'inspirer des bonnes
pratiques de celles qui réussissent
moi je vois que d'abord en finlande on
donne beaucoup plus d'autonomie aux
établissements scolaires d'un principe
sur lequel s'appuie emmanuel macron en
finlande ont fait confiance à l'enfant
on ne cherche pas à l'enfermer dans un
moule
chaque enfant a un talent une forme
d'intelligence individuelle et donc
c'est en prenant appui sur ses capacités
qu'on va lui permettre à cet enfant de
de s'estimer lui même de prendre
confiance et d'avancer et de progresser
et puis c'est la nécessité de réduire le
nombre d'élèves par classe notamment
dans des quartiers difficiles dont les
enfants viennent différentes origines
dont les familles ne sont pas toujours
en mesure de les accompagner dans leurs
démarches scolaire marc tarabella je
vouvoyais sourire pendant le reportage
agréablement pendant les activités
manuelles
oui parce que malheureusement dans nos
pays post industrielle on a des
valoriser les métiers techniques les
métiers manuels
or on en a cruellement besoin et les
pénuries et ici dans l'enseignement
traditionnel on va dire classique on
atteint le travaux manuels
parce que c'est pas cette passe n'est
pas dégradant c'est pas dévalorisant non
clairement je crois que l'enseignement
en alternance dans les pays nordiques
dans les pays germaniques
il faut aussi s'en inspirer l'internet
et de la présence à la fois à l'école et
aussi dans les entreprises est ici bas
en belgique francophone
on l'a mis sur la table maintenant un
pacte d'excellence parce qu'on se rend
compte que l'enseignement doit être
réformé doit être valorisée on doit
avoir un encadrement plus différenciée
il faut évidemment y mettre les moyens
parce que ça mais investir dans
l'éducation c'est pas un coût mais un
investissement les priorités allez on va
terminer par c'est très important chez
king l'évasion fiscale plus le
simulations fiscales coûtent chaque
année 1000 milliards d'euros aux états
de l'union européenne c'est ce qu'a
déclaré en belgique
le ministre président wallon paul
magnette vrai faux c'est notre rubrique
checkpoint préparé par thomas ninian
[Musique]
l'évasion et l'optimisation fiscale en
belgique
le ministre président wallon paul
magnette a lancé un chiffre dans une
interview accordée au journal l'écho
mille milliards d'euros on doit dit-il
récupérer 1000 milliards d'euros par an
qui nous sont volés alors est ce
vraiment le cas prenons d'abord
l'évasion fiscale autrement dit cette
économie souterraine basé sur une
production légale mais qui évite
sciemment les taxes et les impôts
elle a été évaluée à 22 % de l'économie
européenne par la banque mondiale sur 5
euros une pièce échapperait donc
toujours à toute contribution fiscale
au total quel serait alors le manque à
gagner
si l'on calcule les pertes pour chaque
pays en fonction de la charge fiscale et
de l'ampleur du phénomène le total
atteindrait pas moins de 864 milliards
d'euros dressent encore l'optimisation
fiscale
la appelons le la pratique est légale il
s'agit juste par des montages financiers
de profiter des failles du système
quoi qu'il en soit les estimations
varient d'une étude à l'autre mais il
semble que le manque à gagner représente
150 milliards d'euros résultat évasion
plus optimisation cela nous donnerait
effectivement 1000 milliards d'euros de
manque à gagner
tel que l'a affirmé paul magnette herman
van rompuy cité déjà ce chiffre en 2013
et le site internet de la commission
mentionne encore aujourd'hui cette
estimation
mais cette même commission nous indique
qu'elle n'utilise plus ce montant total
car tout d'abord elle ne se risque plus
à évaluer l'évasion fiscale
son ampleur
tout simplement inconnu quant à
l'optimisation fiscale entre 50 et 70
milliards d'euros voilà la dernière
estimation officielle
y aurait-il donc ni les milliards
d'euros à récupérer chaque année l'art
est probable en un commentaire l'évasion
fiscale à fléau en europe est clairement
le matériel a très clairement un fléau
puisque le budget européen apparaît s'il
faut inférieur à cela fonctionne avec un
pour cent du produit intérieur brut de
l'union pour toutes nos politiques et
ici nous avons mille milliards qui
disparaissent qui ne sont pas qu'il ne
rentre pas dans je dirais dans le
circuit et qu'ils sont pas dûment taxe
est là probablement que non seulement la
fraude fiscale et la vraie lutte de la
fraude fiscale mais aussi une
harmonisation fiscale en europe est une
clé pour l'avenir
il n'est pas normal que les sociétés de
paris en ligne par exemple soit tout
basé à gibraltar ou à malte pas parce
qu'il ya plus de soleil qu'à paris ou à
bruxelles est tout simplement parce
qu'il ya une taxation 0 il ya une
concurrence l'irlande abrite de
nombreuses sociétés y compris des
multinationales il n'est pas normal
qu'elle soit sous taxé en irlande alors
quelles sont leurs chiffres d'affaires
sur l'ensemble des pays de l'union
et aujourd'hui je pense qu'on avance
aussi au niveau du parlement européen
avec des mesures qui vont aller vers une
taxation en fonction du chiffre
d'affaires fait dans les différents
états membres
il faut une harmonisation fiscale parce
qu'on peut redistribuer que s'il ya une
fiscalité efficace et une harmonisation
et qu'on arrête de se faire notamment au
niveau de l'impôt des sociétés une
concurrence qui est préjudiciable aux
états qui appliquent une fiscalité qui
est jugé par d'autres trop élevé mais
qui permet de redistribuer vers les
citoyens en termes de services publics
en termes de jeu dirait de biens et de
services publics qui sont plus
accessibles que dans notre pays où
parfois il n'existe pas aujourd'hui je
pense que nous sommes là comment pour
lutter au fait de ce qui pourrait être
le pacte européen parce que le pacte
républicain est fondée sur le paiement
de l'impôt la relation entre le citoyen
contribuable et l'institution et qui
répond à ses attentes de sécurité
d'éducation de santé de solidarité on a
vu
des situations qui ont qui ont déclenché
des scandales luxe mix panama peppers
football luxe récemment
de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit en fait de
concurrence de dumping fiscal entre les
états membres de l'union européenne
il ya l'aspect fraude je suis pas sûr
que les fraudes l'emportent sur le
manque à gagner du fait d optimisation
fiscale
les optimisations c'est de tirer profit
des concessions faites par les états
mans pour payer le moins d'impôt
possible
on est très choquée lorsqu'on apprend
que des multinationales telles que
google epl amazon ikea un mcdonald's
starbucks ne paie pas d'impôt en europe
mais s'ils ne paient pas d'impôts c'est
du fait de la bêtise des états membres
de l'union européenne qui font des
concessions ce qu'on appelle le taxent
ruling alors probablement que la
situation va évoluer mais je pense qu'on
pourrait ouvrir un vrai débat devant
l'opinion publique européenne sur ces
questions fondamentales sur les sur les
fraudes fiscales on sait qu'il ya par
exemple dans le domaine de la tva ce
qu'on appelle des carrousel qui
permettent à des aigrefins 200 pocher
des sommes considérables au détriment
des finances publiques des contribuables
et des citoyens et bien tout cela
pourrait être endiguée à mon avis s'il y
avait une plus grande intégration
fiscale au sein de l'union européenne
alors naturellement c c'est l'ultime
effort à accomplir pour que l'europe
soit bien comprise par les citoyens
européens la situation actuelle ne peut
pas durer
il y a urgence à en débattre devant
l'opinion publique ce qui s'est passé
récemment à l'occasion de panama peppers
et de luxe knicks ministre des finances
se sont réunis à bruxelles
et puis au soir d'une journée des
changes
ils ont fait un communiqué nous avons
passé un accord pour lutter contre
l'évitement de l'impôt naturellement
c'est beau comme l'antique et en fait
ils n'ont rien changé parce qu'on est
dans le court termisme et qu'on ne prend
pas à bras le corps avec l'aide et le
soutien de l'opinion publique
la nécessité de trancher ces questions
de donner à l'union européenne un
véritable pouvoir avec ce qu'il convient
de transparence merci en tout cas ce
sera le mot de la fin merci à vous
d'être venus débattre avec nous merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi celle afin de
refaire de la semaine prochaine vous
retrouvez nos ramadi pour un nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo d'ici là bonne
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires et la rtbf 3 ne pas
oublier la rtbf trois balles
[Musique]